et je ne chantais pas assez de chansons festives.
Alors, ils ont dit que les Kényans n'écouteraient pas une Kényane comme moi.
Cette idée d'extranéité,
l'exclusion d'une personne,
fondée sur la perception qu'elle est hors norme,
est à la base des problèmes du Kenya.
Et elle y est solidement ancrée.
Le Kenya a été inventé par des colons en 1895,
puis sont apparus l'effacement de notre identité
et la création d'une société basée sur la différenciation.
En 1963, quand nous sommes devenus indépendants,
ces idées étaient déjà devenues la nouvelle norme.
Depuis, nous avons essayé de progresser de beaucoup de façons.
Avec une langue, une monnaie, des infrastructures communes.
En gros, tout ce qui fait un pays.
Mais tous ces efforts pour construire une nation
ne sont pas le cœur de mon sujet,
qui est le suivant :
on ne peut pas construire ce qu'on n'aime pas sincèrement.
Et on ne peut pas aimer avant de s'aimer soi-même.
Ce que nous devons guérir, nous Kényans,
c'est notre manque d'amour-propre,
notre haine profonde envers nous-mêmes
et notre crise d'identité existentielle.
C'est un travail de construction nationale
que seule l'industrie culturelle peut accomplir.
L'idée que le Kenya ne peut inclure que certains d'entre nous
m'a conduite à créer en 2008 le festival de musique Blankest & Wine,
afin de nous donner une tribune, à moi et à d'autres marginaux.
Dix ans plus tard, plus de 200 groupes y ont joué
et au moins 100 000 dollars ont été remis
directement aux artistes et à leurs agents,
qui les ont à leur tour investis en techniciens, en répétitions,
en clips vidéo, ou ailleurs dans la chaîne de valeur de l'industrie musicale.
Notre plateforme a permis l'existence de plusieurs identités kényanes,
tout en incitant l'industrie à découvrir et à échanger
avec la riche variété musicale kényane.
Ce que nous faisons est nécessaire, mais insuffisant.
Nous devons urgemment nous tourner vers une tournée de concerts live.
Mais la musique peut aider à réconcilier notre nation de bien d'autres façons.
Selon un rapport sur les médias en 2018,
la radio reste de loin le principal moyen de diffuser des idées au Kenya,
avec 47% des Kényans qui placent toujours la radio en premier choix.
Cela représente une opportunité.
La radio peut servir à faire comprendre aux Kényans la diversité du Kenya.
60% de toute la programmation musicale à la radio pourrait être réservée
à la musique kényane.
On peut faire tomber les barrières ethniques
en jouant de la musique kényane en anglais, en kiswahili,
et dans d'autres langues autochtones,
sur ce qui est aujourd'hui une radio ethnique monolingue.
La radio peut stimuler l'intérêt et la demande
des Kényans pour la musique kényane,
tout en lui fournissant les revenus dont elle a besoin
grâce aux droits d'auteur.
Mais plus important encore,
la radio peut nous aider à construire un récit plus inclusif sur le Kenya.
Car on ne peut pas aimer ce dont on ignore l'existence.
D'autres industries culturelles peuvent aussi y contribuer.
Quand on sait que pour 41% des Kényans,
la télévision est le média principal,
le cinéma a évidemment un énorme potentiel.
Les maigres ressources investies dans ce secteur
ont déjà produit des vedettes mondiales
comme Lupita Nyong'o et Wanuri Kahiu.
Mais, nous aurons besoin de plus d'incitations et d'investissements
pour faciliter les tournages au Kenya,
pour qu'il y ait davantage de récits kényans à la télévision
et pour déclencher les conversations très difficiles
que nous devons avoir entre nous.
Nous allons avoir besoin de beaucoup plus de vedettes nationales
afin d'inverser le préjugé selon lequel
notre succès doit se faire à l'étranger
avant d'être acceptés et estimés dans notre propre pays.
La mode peut aussi y prendre part.
Nous devons faire en sorte
que la production de masse de vêtements kényans pour les Kényans
ne dépende plus d'importations d'occasion.
La première chaussure de course kényane
doit connaître un succès national et mondial
pour célébrer l'excellence kényane
incarnée par les coureurs kényans qui sont d'envergure internationale.
Pour que ces idées prennent vie,
des emplois seront créés,
et les idées du Kenya dépasseront ses frontières.
Mais plus important encore,
les Kényans pourront enfin se sentir dignes
de l'amour que nous réservons aux autres.
L'industrie culturelle kényane est dynamique,
cosmopolite, tournée vers l'avenir,
et, sans aucun doute,
elle sera une véritable industrie productive dans un futur proche.
Mais son vrai pouvoir réside dans sa capacité à guérir l'âme du Kenya
pour que nous puissions enfin construire une véritable nation.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Pour cette chanson, j'aimerais prendre une minute
pour que nous pensions tous aux migrants,
et particulièrement aux réfugiés,
à la lutte quotidienne qu'ils doivent mener
pour se construire une vie digne de ce nom,
loin de tout ce qu'ils ont aimé et connu.
Si vous êtes touché par cette idée,
je veux vous voir lever le poing en l'air.
(Musique)
« Un million de voix. »
Tout le monde, faites du bruit
Avec un million, un million de voix
Je ne peux pas m'arrêter, Je ne m'arrêterai pas
Dédicace à tous ceux de mon peuple qui construisent quelque chose
Qui travaillent dur pour que leurs enfants ne manquent de rien
Quand les gens viennent et disent qu'ils sont premier degré
Je suis morte de rire et je leur dis d'examiner toutes leurs possibilités
Attention, déformation naturelle
Tu ne peux même pas nous tuer, on survit même à l'avortement
Tu dis qu'on ne peut pas réussir, mais regarde-nous le faire,
Regarde-nous dans une minute comme on court pour tout dépasser
TED, applaudissez !
Je ne peux pas en avoir assez
C'est notre seule façon de vivre
Toujours, toujours travailler dur
TED, applaudissez comme ça
Je ne peux pas en avoir assez
C'est notre seule façon de vivre
Toujours, toujours travailler dur
Tout le monde, faites du bruit
Comme un million, un million de voix
Avec un million, un million de voix
Je ne peux pas m'arrêter, Je ne m'arrêterai pas
Je ne peux pas m'arrêter, Je ne m'arrêterai pas,
Avec un million, un million de voix
Je peux être votre chef ?
Je peux être votre César ?
Si je vous montre comment gagner plus, prêterez-vous allégeance ?
C'est toujours l'un ou l'autre
Toi ou moi ou aucun des deux ?
Si je te montre d'où je viens, tu me laisses tranquille ?
Parce que ce que tu trouveras, Ce que tu trouveras
Ce que tu trouveras, c'est sûr, va forcer ton respect !
Je vais t'impressionner, Je vais t'impressionner
Et là tu comprendras pourquoi je reste sur ma lancée
Applaudissez !
Je ne peux pas en avoir assez
C'est notre seule façon de vivre
Toujours, toujours travailler dur
Je ne peux pas en avoir assez
C'est notre seule façon de vivre
Toujours, toujours travailler dur
Tout le monde, faites du bruit !
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)
La chanson suivante est en partie en kiswahili,
la langue parlée au Kenya.
Et elle évoque l'amitié entre femmes,
le pouvoir de la femme
et des femmes qui s'unissent pour construire un projet durable,
un vrai héritage à transmettre aux générations suivantes.
« Suzie Noma. »
(Percussions)
Assises dans un coin
Suzie Noma et moi
On ne s'angoisse pas on ressemble aux patronnes
On sirote des Coronas
On regarde nos portables quand
Tous ces beaux garçons nous disent combien ils nous désirent
Mambo ni kungoja, aki mtangoja
Sinaga matime za kuwaste na vioja
On planifie comment bientôt conquérir le monde
Portées par les percussions, les applaudissements et les basses
Hé ! Bouge-toi, bouge-toi comme –
Attends de voir, attends de voir mon –
Hé ! Bouge-toi, bouge comme –
Si tu le sais et que tu veux le montrer
Donne l'exemple
Va chercher quelqu'un, bouge ton corps, montre aux gens
Ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais
Iyo !
On manigance dans un coin
Suzie Noma et moi
On n'a pas de thunes mais on fait comme on veut
On se fait les ongles, on regarde nos mails pendant que
Tous ces beaux garçons veulent nous avoir, mais ne peuvent pas
Aki mtangoja, leo mtangoja
Saa hii tukoworks hakunaga za vioja
On planifie comment bientôt conquérir le monde
Portées par les percussions, les applaudissements et les basses
Bouge-toi, bouge comme –
Attends de voir, attends de voir mon –
Hé ! Bouge-toi, bouge comme –
Si tu le sais et que tu veux le montrer
Donne l'exemple
Va chercher quelqu'un, bouge ton corps, montre aux gens
Ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais
Et là tu te plains de ta taille
Et tu fous ton visage en l'air
Tu exagères ta taille
Ressuscite-la
Na wale wako fifty fifty comsi
Na wale wako fiti pia sisi
Tuko tu sawa mdogo mdogo yaani
Hallelu-yawa tumeiva design
Si tu le sais et que tu veux le montrer
Donne l'exemple
Va chercher quelqu'un, bouge ton corps, montre aux gens
Ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais, tout ça je le sais
Iyo !
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)